probably a night of sleep
what's going on how have you been
I've been all right I also just kind of
a bit of a tailspin I suppose
you look good except you're
a little disheveled and sleep deprived
your eyes are the same color as your
dress
I guess that's my calling card I don't
know it seems to be at this point in
your life
I think I think there'll be another
chapter in your life that looks very
different than this one what do you mean
I think you'll
get tired of this lifestyle and you'll
maybe straighten out a little bit
just growing up sometimes
maybe a little therapy
I don't know
have you ever talked with a therapist
um I got some I don't know
it's always helpful
for everybody
last time you were here you want to talk
you were talking about being you wanted
to be a star yeah I do
you always make you I was thinking about
this after you left you know what would
make you the biggest star possible in
today's
crazy world that we're in what you doing
a little series of updates on going to a
rehab getting clean the whole world
would be fascinating with that story and
when it's all said and done you'd be
healthy clean and you'd be a star
I think I'd just rather get into the
industry you know what I mean you're not
going to get in the industry in the
state you're in right now
yeah I don't want to be on the street
anymore that's for sure have you have
you had some rough things happen to you
recently
not really just kind of I don't know
you're just tired of it
uh
I'm tired of feeling like
like I'm being harassed for something I
haven't done anything
yeah I mean you probably get a lot of
disrespect just being you look like a
homeless person so you're gonna
you're gonna get a lot of crap
I'm ready to freshen up clean myself up
and really be myself you know what I
mean
rather than disheveled statement I don't
know I think the the drugs are a big
part of your problem
and the therapy might help you that's
that's not the drugs it's just
I don't know there's a part of me that
just like stub
go out you know what I mean yeah yeah
that's okay
you're 25.
it's the age to do that stuff
you're going a little extreme sometimes
sometimes
I don't know it's not like I make
mistakes but you know
it's not the drugs it's just like
I don't know
do you realize how many of my viewers
absolutely love you I know I know I just
you feel it sometimes when you're on the
street and people recognizing yeah I do
yeah people love you not just like you a
lot they
love you I love them I'd love to meet
these on my Farms you know what I mean
get to know people properly
in a more socialized manner rather than
this
state I'm in
how are you spending your days because
you don't come down here much anymore
I know I do and I don't I guess I'm just
kind of used to spend a lot of your time
on skid row now I think you're you're
here you just come to see me once in a
while
well I'm usually around here I don't
know
I just want to go to Hollywood
would you say Hollywood you mean West
Hollywood
I guess yeah
or Hollywood in general
yeah
you can get your
your Molly or your crystal meth there
I guess I can
koi
how do you mean
you're pretending like you're not really
using drugs
I guess I don't know
I think you're amazing thank you hi or
clean or whatever
in any state I still think you're great
thank you
thanks I like your best when you're
clean but
and cleaned up
oh cleaned up too but
you know not not
withdrawing or fiending for
for your next fix
you seem pretty good right now
I know I'm kind of
I don't know
I'm just really disheveled today
honestly that's all right I'll get you a
room
I'd rather just go shopping I'll take
you shopping too
thanks shopping comes first
and then we'll uh see if you're tired
what do you want to go shopping for
I know I just want to get some clothes
some legs maybe some makeup I don't know
get dolled up something to get back into
myself you know what I mean
are you hungry
not really yeah
I'm about getting my
Endeavor to improve I don't know
I don't buy that talk about wanting to
get better
yeah
I don't buy it
it's true though no I mean I know
there's a part of you that sees that
that's what you need to do but
deep down you're not really
fighting to get better
I'm [__] up but I'm ready to like
fix you know what I mean
it's like I'm making a mistake that I'm
ready to just unmake
but you understand that
you would have a huge audience and a
following that would just
attach to you and stay attached if you
went through the progress of the process
of of getting
getting healthier clean
yeah yeah I suppose I just I need to get
like it's like you want to you want a
short cut to getting in becoming a
whatever it is a star celebrity a social
media whatever I guess yeah it would be
the way to do it
no I just I need like
a home and a credit card you know what I
mean like a line of credit you know well
I haven't gotten you a home or a credit
card but but when I've got new things
like phones or a hotel room you you bail
on the room and you sell the phone
I keep the room
I do keep the phone I just no the room
is empty like three hours after I get it
for you
you are wild
yeah
I'm gonna fix up after this we should do
another interview when I'm not all up
I'm sorry you do another interview and
I'm all dolled up you know what I mean
you want to go get go shopping then
we'll we'll do part two of this
I guess yeah
let's do it stores are open sure
okay
thanks
bro
I can't remember
where you want to go
um
I don't know maybe down the street they
have like
I was joking about Rodeo Drive
but I'll take you anywhere downtown
you want the wig you want the whole
thing yeah okay
I thought you weren't here though
is your particular story you like here
um I mean that was the dollhouse or
the dollhouse is great and dollhouse is
just on eighth
oh it's just down there oh the other one
where I took you before
um
all right stupid car
maybe you should go to like the Fashion
District I don't know okay no but we can
we can go to McDonald's as well
yeah we can go to the dollhouse
maybe you had a dress or two I don't
know
like the polka dots huh I like the polka
dots
remember
yeah you can always work so you don't
you don't want us here because I don't
have an appointment I'm sorry you don't
want us here because we don't have an
appointment
so we need to make an appointment yeah
okay we'll go someplace else thank you
I guess we're not welcome here come on
I'll take you someplace then
we'll have us
santioli okay
they didn't want us there
it's LA's Fashion District
doors
sheet very inexpensive clothes right
I suppose I don't know it's not about
inexpensive I mean I I like
to close down here because
um
I don't know it's like accessible but
done well you know what I mean
all right off those weeks before what's
up I'm worried out those wigs before
let's go
you like
um
which pink one not really that long pink
line the hot pink one yeah
beautiful yeah
yeah can I try it on we don't destroy it
thank you
two times
you're feeling blonde today
foreign
I'll store them for you
like the top one on the top right
you want them both
get three
I'll hold them for you
you're having a hard time
I know
um
do you have um
I do
so that'll be how much when
what 110 110. so it's 35 and 75.
there you go
um
um okay I just like take it out of the
box and try it on well we just bought it
so yeah he's not gonna he's not gonna
take it back yeah
you can go back to the studio and we can
change
okay
you see anything you like
it's beautiful
I don't know
I'm sorry
what is that what is your question
Rebecca
I just want to try this on
I don't know if they're gonna let you
try it on but I would just get it
let's just get it anyway get a few of
them
I'm sure can I can I get the fun and
what size
yeah I'm like a zero too
what size uh zero or two
I don't know
thank you
beautiful
thank you very much
um you want lunch yeah sure um
we can get uh what do you want a hot dog
um
could I get um
a bacon wrap a hot dog with no buns and
um
you're gluten-free you're gluten free
you're hummus and gluten-free
good for you
like what would you like on it
onions
anything else from here
just the onions
okay
here we go um
you saw that
I'll end up healthy
you got it
I don't understand that who lives in a
tent yeah like look at the indignity you
know what I mean I don't understand
honestly
music
[__]
what are you filming right now [__] ow
uh
ow how do I get to santially huh how do
I get to Santee Alley we were there
yesterday I don't know [__] I don't
know what the area [__]
vodka
[__] my life when you [__] kill
myself [__] [__]
huh it'll sound better if you put your
seatbelt on [__]
people England is foot pain [__]
that's like I'm pregnant
oh
look I need some Molly [__]
[__] they don't like how am I out here
[__] though just Crystal and Crocs oh
yeah [__]
35 bucks so it's so cheap too
it's like a wonder drug you know
because they like oh can you try to cry
yeah I I don't understand it doesn't
really do anything it's like it's like
oh so you know sniffing glue you know
it's not for me oh [__]
well Aaron needs a revamp I don't
understand anything
like why isn't La it's like why is it
all right oh [__]
ah
what day is it today
is uh Friday right
it's been a crazy week because the
fourth is that Friday today is Friday
yeah I didn't do it the Fourth of July
[__] Owen
[__]
see fireworks how do you see any
fireworks no why I hate fireworks way
too loud
you're way too loud what I'm paying [__]
ever been in pain
[__]
something I hate Butler about myself but
I find it really irritating
the other [__] way [__]
other way yeah
they're [__] the other way it's back
around really yeah it is Mark [__] do
you want to live here
[__] it's back there okay I'll turn
around all right
relaxing to kill me
ah
[__]
first I'm gonna get you with shoes
podiatrist I ain't a podiatrist I need
an what is it like what do they call
them in an ear doctor
yeah what's going on with your ear yeah
my ear and my feet I don't know
oh
[__]
anytime ah [__]
there's one store here by the way
there's a really basic store and they're
so rude to me they never let me in
because I [__] yourself a bum
[__] okay
Mike I don't care it's a [__] store
anyway you got kicked out of a store
yesterday because we didn't have an
appointment
yeah it's a [__] [__] story it's an
I don't need an appointment with the
[__] I just don't think they [__] you
oh [__]
ing because I'm dirty it's the beard
honestly
where do you want me to take you
santially you guys take a left here [__]
I left here yeah I don't really know
where it is out here
oh [__] it it is the other way around
okay let's go over there we have they
have clothes over there just oh [__]
there's uh yeah Ellie wholesale Fashion
Mart or whatever yeah
I finally clear all the tents here [__]
am I gonna have my crystal from
[__]
[__] God
the [__] is this [__]
there's something I hate about being
home is like oh
no Mark oh [__] nope
wholesale Mart take a left here
[__] God you're bossy huh you're bossy I
I know sorry I can't at least when I'm
irritated like everything's shut today
[__] take a left here
[__]
kill myself you wanna Park no not here
Mark [__] Santa always right around the
corner essentially he's way back there
whenever [__]
[__]
oh so where's your uh
where are you going yeah I'm going [__]
you always walk this area [__]
I find scrapped some crows under bridges
so what's going on with your ear
oh it's hurting
no my ears like is that infection it's
like it's full of something like
it's blocked or something
like you want to get a nose block
it's like that but in my ear and then my
feet are [__] killing me what's worse
your feet are here my feet hurt more
maybe this is really annoying
there's something in your ear yeah I
don't know what it is though like if I
put a second at your army like a metal
stick it'll clear it oh
you know literally don't put a metal
stick in your hair no that's all I do no
no that's all I do in my life is I
[__] think I'm gonna stick in my ear
[__] rub my feet I'll take you to
some places you can clear out your ear
hopefully
[__] I went to hospital they couldn't
diagnose that [__]
sorry
I'm pregnant you don't even [__] you're
a handful I'm sorry
I hit that wrong though I'm really ah
oh
[__]
oh my God it's illa
no not here um okay [__] [__] [__] okay
you gotta say it right here almost there
[__]
because they're actually bleeding today
I can't last night
why is everything saute [__] that's a
nice wig
oh you bought it
that looks good on you
thank you
a bit run I'm gonna say honestly but I'm
wearing it for since yesterday
I just see it now
so I don't get about anymore you're kind
of like there's like a shiny stew but
you're like
like it kind of rounded me
like like you're very socially awkward I
guess
yeah I'm not not smooth
you should be though I mean I guess I
like it
oh
[__] kill it kill it kill it before he's
done [__] drop my feet off
we're gonna get a chainsaw
um is this where we're going
um yeah take it off here [__] I'm just
parked yeah that's all ah
oh [__]
[__] so your exercise isn't down there
[__]
sorry
no way
I'm sorry
oh [__]
yeah it's not closed yesterday
[__]
look who's on here [__]
on here ah
no not here [__] we gotta go around
today
what time is that it's 11 o'clock is it
weird enough summer open take that left
here oh no is it here or is it ah [__]
out oh
you don't pay me for the video Yesterday
by the way
I'm sorry you didn't pay me for the
video yesterday
yeah you went and got high and
disappeared you didn't pay me for it I
know you you've disappeared you got high
and disappeared I know are you ready
what you ended up in the room which is
good
oh
this is way too much pain now
where the [__] is everyone
who the [__] are we do you get off here
maybe I don't know
it might as a life
[__]
your girlfriend is dead [__]
all right take it out of here we'll go
shopping here [__] I've never been in
the boutiques here Owen
[__]
you see your feet hmm
you were talking about this honestly
I don't like the uh it's it's the back
of it oh um
you can't even see it
oh
Mike can you help me get my life
together
I can't even like this okay
Mike Angel promise me [__]
say it again I need your help you got my
life together okay how can I help you I
said help me get an apartment [__] well
you're not No One's Gonna hire you in
the state you're in right now uh Mark if
I [__] had a house and money I'm not
here [__] uh
go forward go forward
anyway they also shoes here oh [__]
[__]
[__] it no no no
I want that one oops
[__]
where am I checking
oh I left her straight I mean right or
straight
up
this is
um forward
everything's open
yeah is it open oh
no no that's what it oops I got no no no
no no no I'm
no
I'm very judging it's Horizon let's try
Luke salary pasta I don't know
what the [__]
[__] okay enough is uh Zeta [__] [__] I
can't keep doing this [__]
no uh
Swiss
um
ah
I need to appear where is everyone [__]
it is weird pretty quiet why are you so
quiet today
oh my God is
Santee Alley would have been easy okay
now let's go there
okay
let's just go there [__]
preferred as more accessible uh yeah
yeah ah
oh my goddess
yeah I really want I want to get surgery
on my feet because they're too big
if I
ever make money in life
[__]
[__] off me
it looks he's like it's like my skin is
cutting itself really
what's wrong with you today why are you
so quiet okay you're gonna work on the
paint threshold huh you're gonna work on
that pain threshold
what do you mean you're just such a
whiny little I'm sorry it's just part of
my um I apologizing for it I hate that
I'm really annoying today oh [__] yes
you are I know I'm sorry I'm very sorry
you're gonna be back at it in about five
seconds though I know when I'm in pain
now I'm gonna [__] Express that hour
like anything I like [__] I can't keep
looking like this all I can tell you
darling is the drugs are going to be a
big what I need an apartment and I need
somewhere to live an identification just
about drugs [__] vodka enough uh
people do drugs [__]
like you're embarrassing yourself
honestly
stop it [__]
I'm I'm I don't have a house Mark [__] I
should just accept that drugs are gonna
be part of Mark I don't have a house I
don't have a roof over my head [__]
I'm getting really rude no seriously
that should be a concern with a human
being [__]
I can't move where to buy water
you put in my bottle of water [__]
I picked cigarette butt up off the side
of the road I'll come Barefoot [__] is
there more drugs
[__]
I'm dead
I'm thirsty
rude oh my God it's [__] um
you're gonna wreck my car here I'm sorry
um
you're a mess I know the [__]
like I kind of have like an apartment up
here you know what I mean
like a like a loft or something get a
job like as a stylist or something you
know what I mean
like I think I think like
I could live that way
I don't want my excuses but like oh [__]
ing you should say [__]
this is all wrong
[__]
it's La [__]
no this is I want to enjoy my life uh
[__] and drugs are the answer for that
my [__] have you ever been to the city
[__] are you in L.A
I'm sorry are you in La Mark I said he
runs on drugs [__] [__]
you know what celebrities you know a
club is America [__] God [__] like
what is wrong with you [__]
I'm telling you I need identification
and a house should I get off drugs
[__] you tell me you you expect me to
get you a house in the state you're in
right now Mark get me a house I need to
live in a house
You're Gonna Leave me outside the road
what the [__]
get me a house
[__]
are you having a house though right
you're very implied no you're really
implied about it I'm really important
yeah no it is really awesome Grand play
yeah I'm terrible yo [__] you [__]
no honestly
but what would you do
like if I were you I would try to get my
life together a little bit [__] got me
a house put a roof over my head Mark
[__]
literally enough
drugs actually you're wearing you over
here I said Sanji alley
oh
because there's weak today [__]
oh my God is that
oh my God
oh [__]
look at that girl back here she's gonna
go back there I did yeah do you know
it's an acceptable state of life to live
in I'm sorry do you think it's an
acceptable state of life
not for me okay well that's my life good
for you [__] at least you're better
than me
no it's just like I will do things you
deserve a house and I don't I will do
things to prevent that
okay well I I love to do that I just
literally what I'm begging you for [__]
did you make a goatee or whatever the
[__] name is a [__] car
nobody gave me a house no what [__] I'm
sorry Mark I'm sorry homeless I'm asking
for a favor [__] I'm actually gonna help
me get a job
oh [__]
just go to where we were yesterday I
don't want to go here [__]
Mike we were just there yesterday I'm
telling you it's right here Mark Google
it it's not here uh what can you Google
that so I got a perfectly good parking
spot you're gonna make me pass it I
don't wanna [__] shop here
there's nothing here
let me just show you where santially is
Mark it's not here I'm telling you it's
not here I don't want to go to make
Queen we're not going to get it down
here for
I'm not [__] Christ Rebecca you're
gonna get hit I'm sorry [__]
you gonna hit me
I don't hit people but if I ever wanted
to to I'm sorry I never did say it would
be the day
I'm sorry
I apologize I haven't been around for
today
I'm sorry you're asking for it but I'm
not gonna do it you [__] do it then
where's the worst thing you're gonna get
is just getting dropped off at the
Continental at your hotel room
I don't have a room in here yet
I need a job
ain't a [__] job
I don't think you're capable of working
I'm capable of working Mark no you're
not yes I am Mark don't really talk to
me that way
nobody tells me that way what the [__]
that's so rude you're just you're I
can't imagine working with you in this
state
yeah because I'm homeless mark
more than homeless at Mark because I'm
homeless I have nothing like [__]
just like [__]
okay um it's more forward
almost there [__]
like I want to go shopping at Barneys
you know what I mean [__]
[__] let me spend five grand on you do
it [__] I think I'm not worth it there
it is
huh yeah that's what I told you it's
right here
okay [__]
but I had a parking spot a block away
and you said no don't you don't want to
go there
oh [__]
you're a pain in the ass I'm sorry Mark
I need an ID
I have a life
ah
my god um
[__] God
yeah here here
I had a parking spot right back there
but you said don't park here oh [__]
oh my God what is that
you're a special kind of annoying huh
you're a special kind of annoying I know
I'm sorry I'm sorry uh
it's a really bad mood today [__]
if you hurt I have nothing [__]
did you wake up Mark
like you like a pleasure and other
people's pain
your feet don't look that terrible they
really hurt Martha you're screaming in
pain but I don't see that yeah because
there's so much where are they slashed
right here in Barefoot all night I
caught my feet on glass
[__]
ah [__]
what the [__] is wrong with this area
ah
okay we're getting out huh we're getting
out you know what as soon as I can [__]
handbags
yeah I think it works yeah
no I don't like any other
broke I don't know
here you go you got a green light
all right
thank you very much
a new egg
I got your two eggs yesterday
no
more
thank you
foreign
falling down
tomorrow
we'll take it huh we'll take it yeah
defeated
me
we'll take it
right now you what I remember was on me
right now but right now what do you mean
right now what do you mean right now
I know how I feel about it
there's gotta be something here for you
oh yeah
where do you get them where do you get a
mannequin like that
that's a
that's that's right
so this one is 29.99
it is it doesn't have it
I don't know but oh wait I guess I like
it yeah
I mean you can see it
it has a chain and everything you have
two options you have this one and then
this one this is cute
this is cute
okay I'm sorry dude it's okay
find something we've wasted this girl's
time enough
you don't see anything here you like
there's lots of stuff I like
what do you like
right now okay I'll take care of you
either way okay
thank you for being patient
I like that
thank you we'll take that for sure
what else what else
go crazy here huh stock up you got a
place to keep this stuff now so you you
can stock up
I know Justin Bieber
um
oh there you go now I know again I've
seen your video
what's the name of your store uh
spiritual pain
you have a great story you have a great
store and your personality is great
thank you
got it
oh
okay
whatever
come here
because
tonight
um